i'm not gay do like the ladies big fan
of the old
labia i am
yeah
which is weird because when i was a kid
i hated girls when i was like six years
old i thought girls were gross thought
they were dumb you know you're allowed
to hate girls as a kid but that's really
the only group a kid's allowed to hate
because if i was a six-year-old that
hated
puerto ricans
that would be weird
you know i was like hey mom i hate
puerto ricans she would never say
oh you'll like them one day
you'll like them a lot
yes
hey any puerto ricans here
all right too many
just kidding love a good party good
people very passionate people a lot of
knives but passionate people there yeah
yeah yeah
and these are all jokes by the way take
it easy look i live in new york city all
right if i was racist
i would be exhausted
let's all have a good time
yes but you guys are a good crowd some
crowds get so offended by these dumb
jokes the gay joke puerto rican joke i
got yelled at by a guy to show recently
this guy comes up and goes hey buddy i'm
gay
and puerto rican all right
i don't appreciate those jokes you know
how hard my life is
i was like whoa take it easy how hard
your life is dude
you have the most parades
how bad could it be you know
thank god this guy wasn't half irish
you'd get all the floats
yes
but i realize race is a touchy issue
it's 2014 everybody's weird about race
especially when old whitey talks about
it you know
race is touchy nowadays man everybody's
nervous about looking racist like i was
talking to one guy my last day job and i
was like hey man what's the name of that
new guy on the fifth floor of the really
tall black guy and this guy goes whoa
i don't see color
i was like really do you really just say
that they really just come out of your
face
so i looked this guy right in the eye
and i was like hey man it's cool
i'm black
and he was like no you're not and i'm
like
yes you may not be racist but you are a
liar
i just feel like everybody's so full of
it nowadays everybody's trying to be pc
and it's all fake and phony
overcompensating all the time i was at a
starbucks last week i'm talking my
friend i was like hey you know my
neighbor he's this mexican guy and
before i can finish the sentence this
lady stands up and goes hey
i didn't come here to listen to some
racist conversation
i was like yeah that'd be weird if you
did
it's a coffee shop who would come here
for that
also i said the word mexican because he
is mexican that's not a slur that's not
a bad word sounds like you have some
problem with mexicans you're projecting
that on to me all right
that'd be like him i said yeah this
four-year-old the other day and he went
whoa you give me a bone or a pedophile
come on
oh boy yeah like i like i have four
black friends right now it's the best
i've ever done and um
they all tell me i'm the whitest guy
they know which i'm not sure what that
means uh i guess because i say words
like skedaddle i don't know
i get that all the time
maybe i am super white but i think the
whitest thing about me is the fact that
after i get a haircut i like to leave
the barbershop
yeah don't really see the need for all
the hanging around you know you don't do
that at a dentist's office woo that was
a hell of a root canal and i'm gonna go
sit in the lobby for four hours yeah
and i know some people like hey buddy
that's a stereotype well they made three
movies about it so you figure it out
my black friend gets his hair cut like
six times a day it's crazy
oh boy
i'm learning a lot from my black friends
i'm learning black guys don't get
offended by much it's only white people
on behalf of black people which is very
condescending you know like i was at a
party recently i had a couple beers of
me i was talking a friend of mine black
guy and i was like hey man what's up
with the whole no swimming stereotype
you guys are the best athletes on the
planet you can't backstroke i don't get
it
and you know
and my friend was like yeah we just grew
up in the inner city we'd have a pool
around we'd have a lake to go to i was
like oh now i know and this guy at the
party goes hey man that was ignorant
i was like yeah that's why i asked the
question
now i know more about it how are we
going to get anywhere again learn stuff
all right you're mad at me for trying to
learn about another culture screw you
what does this guy do just walk through
an african studies class like you guys
all make me sick
just trying to learn just because
something makes you feel uncomfortable
for four seconds it's a bad thing if we
did that with everything we wouldn't
learn anything you know your dad's like
hey son i'm teaching about the birds and
the bees oh that makes you uncomfortable
dad look i know girls pee out of their
butts and we'll leave it at that
oh yeah
yes
all right
good crowd
i joke about race but i hate seeing
racism in front of me it's brutal i uh i
used to be friends with this chinese guy
one time we were walking around in
brooklyn somebody called him a [ __ ]
uh he was devastated but can we all
agree that's definitely the gentlest of
the racial slurs
i mean come on he's from china he's a
man not so bad all right
to me i think the names of chinese
restaurants sound a lot more like racial
slurs
let's try some
you know who can't drive
those [ __ ] panda kings
and listen to this one of those golden
noodles just moved my apartment building
oh yes those those guys really burned me
up those lucky dragons
[Music]
all right
oh boy
i don't know right i feel like you got a
joke about race it's it's too uh
you know it's a horrible thing racism so
you got to make i got to make light of
it you know like race just isn't a big
deal to me i grew up in a black
neighborhood i grew up in treme in new
orleans i grew up in a mansion in an
all-black neighborhood those guys hated
me oh yeah
my bike got stolen a million times yeah
it got to the point where at christmas
my mom would buy me a new bike and i was
like oh my god mom what are you doing
this is way too small for jamal
oh man he is going to kick my ass
now
you know a lot of people say to me mark
you grew up in a black neighborhood you
sound like that oh yeah this is how i
rebelled
i was like oh you don't like my people
i'm going 1940s auctioneer on you how do
you like that yes